[Applause]
thank you
last time I was here in DC I had the
chance to be on stage you know what I
did
I came flying just like that many people
have been asking me do you still fly the
answer is yes
I fly every day and I enjoy it and the
hope today many of you join me in this
adventure anyway let me tell you about
my long journey to flying when I was a
young boy my friends and I run around
and explored everything around us we
climb trees we went deep into the
marshland and we jumped we had a lot of
fun we'd go through the thorns through
the shrubs just to see birds I could
tell you for hours about her adventures
with birds but today I want to tell you
about one special bird the grey crowned
crane
I remember watching them when I went to
collect water for my family down at the
bottom of the hill at the valley this
was a highlight of my childhood we would
watch them dancing hear them calling I
always wanted to fly like them you can't
imagine how many times I made pretend
feathers so that I can fly like them I
tried to fly in a fair down and a fair
and a fair down how to go home with
injuries and my parents would do ask me
Olivier what happened to you but I
wouldn't tell because I wanted to try
again and again and again and because I
believed anything is possible as I was
growing up I slowly lost my hope to
flying sad I thought oh never be able to
fly like a crane resin German my country
Rwanda it's so beautiful that anyone can
wish to be a bird to enjoy this beauty's
views but unfortunately my country is
one of the highly populated in Africa
densities have reached over 500 people
per square kilometers and this does not
make make it easy for conservation
my left this is the photo of the
volcanoes national park and it clearly
shows you the line of how people have
pushing vagary culture in e 94 when
genocide happening in my country it
ruined the country I was nine years old
after genocide I wanted to contribute to
rebuilding my country my very first job
was to be a Korea doctor one dream job
for the first time I felt like I was
contributing to building my country by
saving a critically endangered species
in my country but guess what I wasn't
flying Mahad was not in the right place
I started exploring what was happening
with the great crown prince and this is
what I found with less than 500 friends
in my country if nothing was done we
could lose all of them so what's
happening Gregg Fran Kranz have have
been losing most of their habitat but in
addition this is happening there is a
huge demand for pet trade many people
want to have them in their gardens in
hotels as beds so local communities
driven by poverty and lack of awareness
they are hunting poaching and selling to
those who want to have them so crayons
when they end in captivity people cut
feathers to stop them from flying they
never make good pets and we lose a huge
number of cranes by malnutrition people
don't know how to care for them and
stress and most most important these
cranes they can't breathe any captivity
so if Ruth we've lost a huge number of
cranes so when I became aware of this I
told myself I'm gon have to do something
about it
so that's when I founded an organization
to help these cranes with our at met
goal to stop the illegal trade and
remove all the captive grants we have
been implementing a number of strategies
I can't say it all like it's so much of
activities but today I want to tell you
about one strategy
it's illegal to keep Cranston in any
captivity in my country but when I saw
that people really love them and they
want to have them or they are not aware
of the consequences when I decide just
to go any with awareness so we launched
a media campaign we went on radios
television and we taught the people did
you know the cranes that we love could
disappear did you know that our
grandkids our great grandkids might not
be able to see the cranes and the I told
them if we really really love cranes and
you want to give them a second chance
let's do something about it I opened my
phone my private phone number to the
whole country I said like please call me
if you want to register to tell me you
have a crane so many people have been
calling me voluntary we have the gist at
about 288 cranes and when you register
these people accept that we can take
those grants so we've been taking them
confiscating them not confiscating them
but people have accepted so when we take
them we put them under quarantine have
checks and the purpose of this is to
identify cranes that can have a second
chance to go back to the wild and when
the quarantine is finished this is what
happens today we'll be eating 100 credit
in the world
[Music]
[Music]
running some of them flying the hugely
had one friends they like to flock up to
find food together slide together and
every time I see them reminds me how
like as human we need to work in a team
we can't succeed with everything we're
doing without working together present
gentlemen for long time I felt like I
would never be able to fly but recently
I found something every time I release
the captive cranes I see them flying
across my eyes and a fly with them I
can't fly but I want to take something
good that has been happening we will
read about 156 cranes into the world and
these constitute 30% of the whole
population of cranes in my country and
this is not only the only thing that is
happening there's grants they are
coupling and they're having chicks and
this gives me the hope for the Great
crown cranes in my country sadly during
the whole process we've come across a
huge number of cranes that are disabled
many people have accidentally or
purposefully broken the wings so that
the disk currents we never be able to
fly we have over 50 cranes that are in
these conditions but the good news the
government has given us use of 21
hectares in the capital city and we want
to transform this place into a crane
area almost a village it's like a great
round quaint village and we want to
build a huge environmental education
center we want to educate the last
community in in random and this means we
can achieve our goal of not having any
cranes any captivity and we can enter
the tread so if you ever want to fly if
you have ever wanted to fly please join
me together we can end the trade in a
great conference together we can give a
hop to the Great Khan cranes thank you
thank you thank you Olivier what an
incredible story of hope next please
welcome 2019 National Geographic Buffett
award for conservation leadership
recipient Patricia Medici hello everyone
this is a tapir this is a lowland tapir
this is the animal I'm passionate about
this is the most incredible animal on
the face of the earth there's them not
open for discussion this is the the
largest land mammal in South America
they can weigh up to 250 kilos they're
massive they're gorgeous
they live throughout South America and
11 different countries 21 different
ecoregions many different habitat types
forests grasslands flood plains they're
very plastic animals they can be found
in all kinds of habitats they're closely
associated with water they're excellent
swimmers they're fantastic swimmers they
swim super fast they're nocturnal
they're solitary very very elusive
animals very difficult to see a tapir in
the wild very very difficult they're
herbivores 100% fifty percent of their
diet consists of fruit and when they eat
fruit they swallowed the seeds and they
disperse those seeds throughout the
landscape through their faeces and they
have this major major extremely
important role in shaping and
maintaining biodiversity and for that
reason they're known as the Gardeners of
the forest so if tapirs go extinct
forests habitat will be very very
different from what they are right now
this is a baby tapir
the watermelon the cutest animal
offspring in the animal kingdom there is
no competition again not open for
discussion and what makes tapers so
charismatic it's pretty much the baby
tapir so we use these pictures a lot
this is the problem not many people
actually know what a tapir is many
people think this is a tapir this is not
a tapir this is a giant anteater tapirs
do not eat end they do not eat their
mice never ever I told you they eat
fruit the people who do know what a
tapir is particularly in Brazil they
actually associate tapers with lack of
intelligence and that's a whole
different problem because in Brazil if
you want to call somebody let's say
stupid you will call that person and
tapir
it's more or less like like here in the
US like calling somebody a jackass so
that's it that's a huge public relations
problem that we we are trying really
hard working really hard to try and
solve and it's only in Brazil and we
don't really know where it comes from
we're trying to figure that out
so since 1996 we have been working
throughout the country and all the
different biomes where tapers are found
in Brazil we have stablished research
and conservation programs in the
Atlantic forest in the Pantanal in the
Sahad oh and right now at this very
moment were establishing our fourth and
final program in the Brazilian Amazon
and we work mostly outside of protected
areas in private land where we're most
needed in in each one of the regions in
each one of the biomes we identify and
make assessments of all the different
threats affecting papers in that
particular region which usually includes
habitat destruction Rocio is a very
serious problem for tapirs throughout
Brazil throughout South America
pesticide contamination and and poaching
said once we have that information once
we finish those assessments we have all
the data we need to
design and implement local strategies
for their conservation in all these
different regions throughout the country
and over the years over the past 20 23
years we have captured we have
radio-collared we have monitored
hundreds of tapers throughout the
country so we have tons tons and tons of
information coming in every day and
those pieces of information they're
extremely important to us to help us
design those conservation strategies
that I mentioned before make them
effective make them realistic for each
one of the different regions were we're
dealing with but it's not all about the
science at some point in the in our
history we realized that we were doing
amazing science we were collecting
fantastic data we were designing all
these amazing conservation strategies we
were publishing we were presenting in
conferences but we were more or less
preaching to the converted we were not
talking to the public so we decided that
communication had to be a big component
of the work we do in Brazil and Brazil
is huge we have lots of people in my
country so a good part of our energy is
spent communicating talking to the
general public using all the different
tools that are available out there
social media networks art photography
film TV Brazilians love television the
press we use everything we can to talk
to the public as often as possible to
spread the word about the tapir
conservation cause as widely as possible
in Brazil mostly but also
internationally and Brazil is going
through several important changes right
now I'm sure you're all aware of that we
have a new so-called president in the
country and all our our conservation
environmental agencies all our
legislation all our environmental policy
everything is being dismantled
completely dismantled by the minute as
we speak
and all of us
conservationists in Brazil and around
the world we have to stand up for this
fight we have to speak up we have to
make sure we'll be heard throughout this
process we know it's gonna be hard and
painful but we have to do that and
speaking for myself all I can say is
that I will keep doing whatever I can
I'll do whatever it takes to make sure
that this animals and all the habitats
were there still found will not go
extinct thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you Thank You Patricia I'd love to
go see a taper out there in the wild
wouldn't you yeah so if you're joining
us tomorrow night for the awards program
dinner you'll have a chance to hear even
more about Patrice Patricia's incredible
work our last speaker for this session
is a very familiar face for many of you
we call him the Batman around here
because he really is the real Batman and
he's always available to advise you on
your best choice of tequila join me in
welcoming biologist and National
Geographic Explorer at-large
Rodrigo modeun no I don't fly either
I do not fly so when the National
Geographic asked me to share some
stories and some lessons about how to
put a species on the map I immediately
started thinking well what map what is
the map so this is a result of the
reflections that I've been going through
since they asked me and it's a it's a
joy that I hope that I'll be able to
convey some of these lessons to you all
oops I have to go back this situation of
putting a species on the map is not an
easy thing to do because you have to
start from how do how do you begin by
finding a species I'm gonna talk about
two cases two species two different
species
when you choose a species you don't
choose the species because it's very
beautiful
or because it's very charismatic in fact
most of the time the species chooses you
and they choose you by instigating
passion and by posing incredible
questions and fascinating challenges
that you really want to getting engaged
in and that you feel that you may have a
little bit of a solution for the
problems that are affecting those
species so it's really the opposite
species chooses you when you're talking
about about baths can you believe that
there's people who are horrified about
that how can that possibly be but
unfortunately it is true however there's
many ways in which you can turn the tide
around and make people adore bats and
I'm talking about when you're talking to
kindergartners or senators or governor
so whatever local communities anybody
you start talking about the ecosystem
services that bats provide to you and to
them and the fact that bats touch every
day of your life and then they start and
they start figuring out oh yeah but
they're not that horrifying after all
this is exactly the message that we need
to convey when you work on bats you have
to do a lot of research you have to work
with many maps what are the maps that
you're working on this is just one
collection of maps but there's so many
other maps in this case it's the federal
government and the industry and the
multilateral and environmental agencies
but you also have to work with the local
communities with the children in the
schools and so on and so forth and each
of those is one different map and you
have to work on those and many other
maps so you have to put your species on
all of those maps shifting gears let's
go to the Jaguar Jaguars have a very
powerful and positive image already to
begin with right people like Jaguars
right
however Jaguars get in trouble very
often
they attack cattle and that is a problem
that we created ourselves because we
invaded the land of the Jaguar and we
put these animals in front of them and
we remove their original prey and we're
asking them not to touch our animals
what I'm sorry that is a problem that we
created to do this to solve these
problems you have to do a lot of
research and research involving finding
out what are the what are the movements
of the animals one of the spatial
ecology the diet of the animals here you
can see a member of my team and Tony
Lila Torre who is probably here in the
audience I hope somewhere here that's
right he's not here thank you very much
but he is one of the top Jaguar experts
in the world and with him we've done a
lot of this work once you have your
science in place please please publish
if you publish you are going to have the
respect of your peers and you're going
to have the credibility of science but
publishing is not all and to paraphrase
Sir Winston Churchill publishing is not
the end polishing is not even the
beginning of the end
polishing is the end of the beginning we
need to sit down with every P every
group of stakeholders and work with them
get each and every one of your lessons
digest it and put it in their hands so
that they can get your science and your
findings and they can put them in there
in their everyday practices or into
public policy or both but if you don't
have the science there and if you don't
have the publishing there then you don't
have the credibility you have to have
both some of the results that we have
achieved over the years in the case of
the VATS is number one that bats are now
stable all of the all of the colonies
that we've been following for the past
30 years are either stable or growing
and we have new
in many places we have delisted a
species of bat and we're in the process
of working towards the listing several
other species of bats thank you thank
you very much thanks a lot we have
achieved the routing of the outreach and
education today we're not the only ones
by far we're not the only ones that are
talking about bats in a positive light
there's many other people that are doing
this and this is exactly the commitment
the commitment that we want to instigate
in the Mexican public and everywhere
else there's also a new generation of
conservation scientists already working
in their own countries in Mexico in
Latin America in Asia in Africa and many
other places where we've been working so
this is really putting a species on the
map in the case of the Jaguars we have a
very strong program on Jaguar
compensation in which responsible
ranchers get their money whenever a
Jaguar attacks a head of cattle if they
have respected the original prey of the
Jaguar if they did not hunt any any
Jaguars either and if they're not
deforesting if they do that I am very
happy to report that this year we
celebrated case number 400 in which the
federal government of Mexico paid
compensation because of these
responsible ranches that are working
with us for the conservation of the
tower ten years ago we achieved the fact
that Mexico became the first country in
the world to have an estimate of how
many Jaguars do we have and because of
us doing a second national Jaguar survey
last year we can now report that the
Jaguar population grew by 20 percent
last year to 4800 Jaguars in all of
Mexico so that is a thank you
thank you very much again it's putting
the species on the map on a much bigger
way you need to get out of your comfort
zone being there an academic I never
dreamed that I would be working in the
multilateral environmental agreements so
it took me a big effort to get out there
and start working inside is you have to
get out of your comfort zone we have to
create an enable communities of change
we need to do that do not take yourself
too seriously don't take yourself too
seriously come down of the ivory tower
you are just one more human being and
you can interact with everyone else
having a PhD is absolutely nothing
nothing you have to come down from the
avert our work with other sectors reach
out if you're an academic work with the
government's if you're a local
practitioner work with academics etc etc
and never ever give up thank you very
much
[Applause]
Wow that was amazing Thank You Rodrigo
now that we've gotten to know a few cool
species and very excited to introduce
you to a one very very cool animal that
all of you will get to experience right
here but before that let's watch this
short video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our next group of speakers are here to
share much more information about the
charismatic Sumatran rhino to introduce
them our moderator is the senior
director of wildlife at National
Geographic Society where she oversees
the grants portfolio for wildlife
research and conservation projects
please welcome Kathryn workman the
Sumatran rhino holds several Rhino
superlatives it's the smallest the
hairiest the most vocal the closest
living relative of the extinct woolly
rhinoceros and it's the most threatened
of the five living Rhino species its
home is in the sundaland hotspot when of
earth's most biologically rich yet
threatened terrestrial areas
historically it was found across
Malaysia and Indonesia and as far north
on the mainland perhaps as China and
Bangladesh today however wild Sumatran
rhinos are restricted to the forests of
Indonesia mostly on the island of
Sumatra as well as also on Kali mantan
the Indonesian side of the island of
Borneo now it's a tough species to
survey because they're mostly solitary
animals but population estimates as you
just saw are less than 80 individuals
and the population is decreasing in fact
experts now consider isolation to be the
single biggest threat to the species
animals aren't finding each other to
mate and so they're not making enough
Rhino babies something that our
panelists will elaborate on in just a
minute so I can be in a panel on the
smashing rhino
well this species represents an
incredible amount of evolutionary
history being the only living member of
the most primitive group of rhinos that
emerged 15 to 20 million years ago
should this small Harry singing species
blink out it would be the first
extinction of a full mammalian genus
since the Tasmanian tiger disappeared in
1936
but there's a more optimistic reason for
us to have our conversation today and
that is that in partnership with the
Indonesian government the conservation
community has United in an unprecedented
effort to bring the species back from
the brink should the effort succeed this
heralds a new model of conservation
moving forward so to talk about that
effort and all things smart and Rhino we
have a great panel for you I do want to
say very sadly that the National
Geographic fellow on this project whose
name is Rudy Putra and who himself hails
from the island of Sumatra was
unfortunately unable to join us at the
very last minute so Rudy will not be on
the panel today but we have four
terrific folks who I'm going to
introduce now so Colby Bishop is the
manager of programs wildlife programs
for the National Geographic Society
Corps Aegis kal ski is a conservationist
and National Geographic labs fellow Kira
Milam is the director of strategic
partnerships for the IUCN Species
Survival Commission and CCC vert is the
deputy director of the International
Rhino foundation please welcome our
panelists
[Applause]
welcome guys
Cece we're gonna start with you on the
end there because you and your
organization the International Rhino
foundation IRF for this conversation
have been working on so much and I know
conversate conservation for decades so
introduce everyone here in the audience
and online to the species sure thanks
so the Sumatran rhino is a species on
the brink of extinction some even
consider it the most endangered land
mammal on earth there are fewer than 80
individuals as you said and they are
distributed across mostly in Sumatra
across ten small sub populations and
some of these sub populations are so
tiny they're as small as two or three
individual animals the Sumatran rhino is
so it's isolated and in addition to that
with a small number the third problem is
that the females have a reproductive
pathology so the longer the females go
without breeding the more likely they
are to grow tumors or cysts in the
reproductive tract so the problem is the
longer they are isolated the less likely
they are to successfully breed if they
do have the opportunity to come together
and have a reproductive act so anyway so
so looking at this species back in 2015
a group of scientists came together and
they did what's called a population
viability analysis and they looked at
all these factors like this small
population and genetic and demographic
changes and they realize that any
population that's smaller than 15
animals will essentially just sort of
die off in a quiet way where they're off
into existence and and that is all based
on zero poaching and zero human
little Sebastian so that's zero poaching
and zero human mitigated threats so
these tiny populations are highly at
risk of just disappearing into nowhere
in the absence of other threats just by
the very nature of their isolation right
right so if they aren't brought together
if they aren't breeding regularly in a
larger population then we're going to
lose this whole species and are actually
going to leave the whole genus because
it's a it's not just a species it the
entire genus yeah yeah so Kira
given that what Cece just laid out for
us what is the Sumatran rhino rescue
effort how was this conceived who's
involved and what is this effort trying
to achieve sure um so as Cece said
there's been decades of science and
efforts to save so much in rhino but
they just really weren't as a species
stepping back from that extinction cliff
despite many fantastic efforts and so
what we needed was one strategy a one
plan approach that bought the
government's and the NGOs and the global
scientific community together to work as
one team to save the Sumatran rhino and
so in doing that the world community of
scientists worked with the Indonesian
government officials to really come to
an agreement that the only strategy at
this point in time to save so much from
rhinos was to find those isolated
populations and relocate them into
specifically built designed breeding
facilities to really grow the population
with the intention of once the
population has grown getting them back
out there into the wild and so last year
we came together in a project a
groundbreaking collaboration led by the
Indonesian government unfortunately
there's no one here from the Indonesian
government partnership representing
today but we would like to express our
heartfelt thanks for the leadership in
this initiative but we brought together
five founding organizations in the
National Geographic the IUCN Species
Survival Commission International Rhino
Foundation and also in the room today
World Wildlife Fund WWF and global
wildlife conservation so these five
conservation organizations came together
with the Indonesian government to create
an alliance that would work together
with conservation organizations on the
ground so implementing partners
with technical experts around the world
bringing together veterinary expertise
technology expertise husbandry
communication and fundraising to really
work on one plan and so from that we've
created the Alliance each of those
partners have put in a million dollars
each but towards a much larger
fundraising goal with a commitment to
work together to reach that goal and
work with all of those partners to make
sure that this effort is a success and
what is that what's the timeline of that
so we're we've got an ambitious three
year fundraising timeline but obviously
this project is much longer than that
the implementation plan at the moment
spends five years and we're one year in
so another four years but obviously
we're working very closely with the
Indonesian government on a rescue and
breeding effort so this fits within a
wider Indonesian government initiative
of a national breeding strategy for so
much and Rhyno so the intention is to
bring those rhinos in establish these
facilities so there are three objectives
for the project one is to build two new
centers one in Indonesian Borneo one in
northern Sumatra and to expand the
existing facility in Wei campus National
Park in southern Samara and then to find
these rhinos relocate them into these
centers and then establish a breeding
program working through the challenges
that Cece just mentioned with their
reproductive pathology and then work
with the Indonesian government and the
communities and implementing partners to
ensure that it can be carried into the
long term for the survival of the
species
excellent great thanks so Colby as your
advantage from your vantage I guess as
director of wildlife programs what role
did you see for National Geographic here
what what contributing value did
Geographic want to add to this alliance
yeah definitely so as Kira and CeCe set
up for us over decades of research have
and science have gone into figuring out
how how'd the Sumatran rhino works we
know how to take care of it in a
sanctuary we know how stomata rhinos can
mate and how to successfully breed them
in a sanctuary so national Geographics
unique role on this effort is to put the
Sumatran rhino on the map and we just
had a fabulous panel talking about
bringing these lesser-known species
species that maybe people haven't heard
about live in faraway places
there's only 80 left are
is to take pictures like this this is
Joel sir Tori's photo arc image of a
Sumatran rhino so people can look into
the eyes of these species that maybe
they've never seen before see the hair
on its back and get to know it we we
just had our storytelling team down at
one of at the sanctuary in way canvas
and Indonesia and they were there to
film with the seven Sumatran rhinos that
live there but also to get to know and
tell the stories of the keepers that
work so closely with the Sumatran rhinos
and the veterinarians that live on-site
with the Rhinos to make sure that
they're healthy and then of the
surrounding communities as well that
have community gardens to help feed the
Rhinos so our job really is to tell the
20 million years of evolutionary history
that's at stake and gain public support
and get everyone involved on this
important effort very cool Wilson Cory
you have an interesting resume you have
the 3d scan of the tomb of Christ
you've digitized the mummified remains
of a dinosaur in Canada so what exactly
what exactly is the contribution of your
role of Technology your type of
technology to this Sumatran rhino rescue
effort good question so I've been
developing technologies for exploration
and scientific study with National
Geographic for about 10 years and while
doing this I realized that there's
another critical use of these
technologies and that's to be able to
show people some of these places we work
in a different light in a way using
these technologies that they couldn't
otherwise experience and my team and I
have built some pretty wild things we've
built color night-vision cameras to look
up in the trees of jungles to see
nesting chimpanzee families and see how
they interact at night we've built deep
water systems that have been able to go
miles back in caves and take underwater
images some of the highest resolution
underwater images of the world of these
incredible places and even equipment to
work in really harsh environments like
to take time lapses from everywhere from
Mount Everest Antarctica for the extreme
ice program but you know following along
with this mission a couple years ago we
started doing 3d scanning mostly of
cultural and big natural places that are
in danger in some fashion so that we
could preserve
and protect and share them so we scanned
as you mentioned the tomb of Christ
Church of the Holy Sepulchre which was
part of a big museum exhibit here at
National Geographic we've scanned the
entire Nabataean city of Petra Jordan in
submillimetre resolution all of chichén
itzá in interior of all the buildings
tombs that hadn't been accessed for a
hundred years with my friend guerra mode
yonder and natural places like the
Okavango River Delta about a thousand
square kilometers of that and a thousand
square kilometers of Garamba
in the National Park in DRC with my
friend Naftali Hoenig and they're using
that at African parks for anti-poaching
efforts so with all these crazy big
places that we've scanned you might
think that when National Geographic
contacted me and said hey do you think
you could 3d scan a living Sumatran
rhino that then maybe that would have
sounded easy but it didn't I almost
almost said no actually so the challenge
there is is that when we're scanning
these these cultural sites like big rock
temples they're basically the same for
years and years and years at a time so
our normal method of scanning is to
bring six or eight people to a site and
work at it for a month to do this big
area 3d scan it's a millimeter
resolution but the problem with living
animals of course is that they move and
so we basically have to do the same scan
that we do in these big places but do it
in the millisecond so you know that that
scared me quite a bit but I knew that if
we managed to pull this off that we'd
have something incredible we'd have not
just we'd have a experience of the Rhino
that if we digitized the Rhino made a
digital copy and did video reference for
all the motion analysis we'd have
something we could share with the world
and give everybody an up-close look at
the Rhino and give them a way to be
inspired and to share their I know that
they'll probably never be able to see in
the wild we thought this could be so
much more than a flat image we thought
this could actually maybe we could even
take the Rhino and we could put it in
the room with you
you could hear its footsteps you can
hear its vocalization and get the
experience of it walking next to you so
meet Harappan Sumatran rhino how the
heck did you make that happen well so we
traveled on-site my wife and I traveled
to Sumatra where we worked with the
Sumatran rhino rescue there to actually
3d scan the creatures so we instead of
doing a single hairpin yep instead of
using a single camera on lots of people
we used lots of cameras so we could set
them all up outside of the enclosure
that he voluntarily goes in everyday
lured by watermelon to receive
veterinary care
so these bars were nice and wide apart
so we could actually put our camera
system outside of them looking through
the bars of the enclosure so the Rhino
wouldn't destroy our cameras which was a
big concern and you know it rained hard
every day so we had this type over the
top that was already part of the
enclosure that we could keep the cameras
dry but we set up this array of 18
cameras in this case all high resolution
still cameras and our idea was is that
we could fire them all at the exact same
time and capture a 3d scan in the same
fashion that we would one at a time for
a big archaeology site so we set up this
big array of cameras pointed at the
Rhino and got them all focused at where
we would think the Rhino would stand and
this is part of the hard part right
getting a large Ryan over to stand
exactly where he wanted to is not
necessarily easy but fortunately he's
very food motivated and he loves
watermelon so exactly so we were able to
get that done and so ends in
enclosure there as we're doing
focus-test so she's standing exactly
where we want the Ryan tortoise can't
stand and he's all cut they're back to a
group of boxes that synchronized the
cameras through within a millisecond
from each other so that we could fire
the button at once and capture the Rhino
from every angle and just like your two
eyes give you stereo vision by the inter
ocular distance of your eyes we
basically had 18 cameras so we had 18
factorial which is a really big number
of eyeballs eye pairs of eyes looking at
the Rhino developing a 3d scan of him
and because we were doing it from one
side we'd take an image of him from one
side and then have the watermelon moved
to the other side so we'd have him turn
around and piece by piece we built up
this entire scan of the Rhino so you can
see the 3d model that we came out with
here and then you are as you already saw
we can animate the Rhino and bring him
back to life we built up a virtual
Sumatran jungle to play some back end so
that people could experience them in his
environment and when you're done here if
you go across to the cafeteria we have a
large 3d dome with glasses that you can
experience the Rhino in the SMAW Tran
jungle so it was a pleasure and an honor
to work with this amazing animal and I
hope that by helping you to share them
with the world we can make more people
care about them and continue to protect
this amazing animal it's amazing and it
was fabulous to see the front row try to
try to pet hair phone as he passed by
it's incredible
Cory really that is but see see this is
not the first time that hair pan has
been in the States first time in our
auditorium here certainly but hair pan
has history in the u.s. going back to
the 1980s right well yeah he was
originally born here but the whole
history of captive Sumatran dinos goes
back to the 80s back in the 80s
scientists were realizing that this
population was starting to plummet the
numbers were going down and at that time
the estimated population was anywhere
from 400 to 800 individuals and so in
1984 a group of scientists came together
in Singapore and decided that they would
capture Sumatran rhinos and bring them
into zoos around the world to create a
insurance population so to speak so that
if God forbid the wild population did
disappear we would have a backup
population
so approximately over 10 years
approximately 40 animals were captured
including hairpins parents and they were
dispersed across zoos all around the
world and this was an incredible
opportunity because Sumatran rhinos
hadn't been in the care of zoos before
so it was an amazing opportunity to
learn about both their husbandry and
care as well as their nutrition because
you know you think about what a white
rhino eats he's just a big lawnmower in
South Africa and then you think about
the landscape that a Sumatran rhino
lives in there's no wide-open fields of
grass they're eating twigs they they
love their watermelon there are very
food motivated but they eat hundreds of
different species of plants so this was
an incredible opportunity to learn about
this species so unfortunately we were
learning about a lot about the species
but babies were not being born by 1995
there were only 3 Sumatran rhinos left
in the u.s. there is one over in LA and
then there were two in Cincinnati Zoo
and so the decision was made to bring
them all together so that we could try
and focus our last efforts on on making
Rhino babies at that time dr. teri Roth
was hired at Cincinnati and she had one
to one main goal which was to make
babies Rhino babies sorry carry and and
so she they did assessments of the
animals and it turns out that one of the
females wasn't reproductively viable so
that means they had one male apoo and
one female
Emme and so teri put all of her efforts
into trying trying to get a baby out of
these two and so for years she was doing
ultrasounds and trying to figure out
what Emmie cycle was so that they could
they could make this baby and they just
could she was not ovulating and so what
they ended up doing was putting like
putting them together and seeing what
happens and I don't know if any of you
have seen rhinos mate it is not the most
gentle act I'll just say that females
often get quite injured in the process
but they really had no other choice so
they put the animals together and
miraculously they got along pretty well
and a few soon
they're after a me actually ovulated and
that's when Terry sort of craft this
whole nut on Sumatran rhino breeding and
it's the fact that they are induced
ovulate errs so most mammals you know
humans for example will cycle every 28
days but Sumatran rhinos only cycle when
there is an interaction between the
males and females and this is a huge
discovery so once they figured that out
they figured all right we're gonna start
making Rhino babies and so meanwhile
around the same time the International
Rhino foundation and our on-the-ground
partner in Indonesia the Rhino
foundation of Indonesia is also known as
Yowie we established the first Sumatran
rhino sanctuary in why comest National
Park and that's where Hera pan currently
lives and so we had three animals there
but they weren't meeting and so we got
sitting but when we got to make some
babies so now that teri had finally sort
of cracked this nut on the induced
ovulation they actually got a me
pregnant but then she had a miscarriage
so then they got her pregnant again
and then another miscarriage and she had
five miscarriages and we were really
losing hope I mean these were the last
two animals we had to work with and in
captivity
so eventually teri started on a hormone
therapy and it worked
and the pregnancy held and so they just
had to wait the problem is nobody had
had it so much and Rhino pregnant before
so they weren't quite sure how long they
had to wait so turns out 16 months it
takes 16 months to make a rhino baby and
so 16 months later on Dallas was born he
was born in 2001 three years later they
had a little girl named sue Chi and then
three years after that in 2007 Harappan
was born
so eventually Harry's mom and dad passed
away and his sister died of a disease
called iron storage disease which is
significant issue for rhinos but on
Dallas
Hera pans older brother went back to the
SRS in 2007 and he is now the father of
two calves there and a two and Delilah
you saw Delilah doing some photo bombs
and in the background there in the
videos and then
in 2015 the very difficult decision was
made to move Hera pan back to Indonesia
and this was moving the last Sumatran
rhino out of the United States but he
moved in and Asia it was a 53 hour
journey for him they rented out an
entire ferry because they needed they
didn't want to put him on a short flight
and they so they drove the truck into
the ferry he had the whole truck by
himself because they didn't want to give
him exhaust fumes or anything like that
and drove them through the middle of the
night into the SRS and he is a happy
camper there he's he's put on weight
he's loving being in his natural
environment and we are currently working
on getting a hairy baby but it hasn't
happened yet so he's practicing with
some of the females there so if
everybody could wish Harry good luck we
need it and so hopefully we'll have some
more Rhino baby soon yeah it seems like
all the lessons learned back in the 80s
about the reproductive biology are now
being applied to the current effort of
making more smashing rhino baby
absolutely absolutely without the years
of research and studying and husbandry
and care of these animals we wouldn't be
able to succeed
yep that's great good story Kira I'm
thinking that we might have some folks
in the crowd that are perhaps skeptical
of the approach and wonder you know
there's so few of them is this a latch a
last-ditch effort to save this species
so first of all how would you respond to
them and then if you would also put it
in the broader context of other captive
propagation efforts to to save
endangered species sure Katherine what I
would say to them is that the state of
the species that we share this planet
with is in crisis we've heard from the
UN report a few weeks ago that there are
million species slipping towards
extinction and so we are seeing this
situation with more and more species and
but the good news is that we know that
it works and so there are a number of
species now that have been brought back
from very small numbers for example the
Martian Kestrel back in 1970 there were
just four birds left for birds to
breeding pairs but thanks to the
dedicated coordinated efforts of a team
of people and they were able to breed
those birds and get them back and now
there are 300 flying
Mauritius the scimitar horned Oryx
similarly was declared extinct in the
wild by IUCN in 2000 thanks to a really
coordinated effort by the governments by
teams of zoos all around the world and
by global expert communities they've
been reintroducing simmer turn scimitar
horned Oryx now back into Chad and there
are now hundred individuals and they're
on track to reach a goal of 500 back in
the wild in the next few years so we
know that this happens there's a longer
longer list of black footed ferrets
American bison Californian condor many
of them are stories that we know but the
trick is really working together as one
team and all of us all of us fighting to
save species from extinction around the
world the end game the point of success
is having healthy populations back in
the wild in thriving habitats with
functioning ecosystems but there are
many different tools that we need to use
and many different types of expertise to
get us there and often when we just work
with one organization or with our core
community that we tend to use the
techniques we're most familiar with or
the ones that that that we're strongest
in and so what we really need is these
collaborations that bring different
expertise together and sometimes that's
habitat protections sometimes it's
anti-poaching patrols sometimes it's
bringing them into into human care often
it's a combination of all of those and
what we what we do see quite often is a
hesitation to bring animals into human
care as though it's some implication
that we've failed at protecting them in
the wilds but we've just heard from CC
that this is a science it takes a long
time and lots of really really dedicated
expertise to figure out how to capture
an animal how to keep it alive how to
care for it how to breed it how would
how it performs reproductively and
there's lots of nuance into that and we
need we need time we need time and
experts working together to figure out
those solutions and we have recently
seen some devastating consequences of
what happens when we leave it too late
there was an example just two years ago
now a little Melanie so little rodent
off of the island off the coast of
northeast Australia and the island was
going underwater because of rising sea
levels and they knew this and the
habitat for this Mouse was shrinking and
the scientific community and the
government community was
debated what to do about this for five
years they finally decided to bring some
into into human care it took six months
to approve the permits and a few weeks
before the expedition to go and capture
some of these some of these mice a huge
storm surge came washed the island under
water and we've lost that we've lost
that species and similarly the vaquita
porpoise is a very small purpose in the
Gulf of California many of you will know
that really harrowing story we waited
until there were 30 individuals left and
we didn't know a thing about how to
capture them how to keep them alive how
to breed them and despite really valiant
incredible efforts from a global team
that effort is not currently succeeding
and with that the future of that of that
porpoise is really an instrument here
that we know it can work it really does
we just need to work together as a
collaboration and we need to start early
we can't wait until it's the eleventh
hour yeah sense of urgency is that's
really pressing thank you okay so Colby
what is the state of the smashing rhino
rescue effort where all y'all right now
in the project and and what does it look
like for the next five years of this
partnership yeah so right now in the
three areas in Indonesia where we know
there are rhinos in the wild we're doing
surveys to figure out where exactly the
best places to dig the pit traps to
rescue them and bring them into the
sanctuaries this conversation wouldn't
be complete if we didn't acknowledge
pahu who is the Rhino on the screen here
PAH who is our first official rescue for
the project back in November she was
living in a mining concession area in
the Kalimantan region of Indonesia and
we so we rescued her from there and now
she has been relocated to a sanctuary in
that same region and she is happy and
healthy and you can tell she's happy
because she's wallowing in the mud here
and that means she's doing just great so
really our goal is that we'll bring in
more rhinos we'll start to really
understand exactly where they are we'll
bring more in and as Kara mentioned the
end goal is not to have Pabu and a bunch
of rhinos and in a sanctuary forever the
goal is eventually to release them back
into their natural ecosystem awesome
cool
giving up on the protection we're
continuing to protect the natural
forests and we have partners including
the WWF and Rhino Foundation of
Indonesia and Rudy poachers organization
the fellow you just talked about they're
out there day after day 24/7 in the
forests deactivating snares ensuring
that rhinos are safe and they're not
just protecting rhinos they're
protecting elephants they're protecting
Tigers they're protecting scores of
primates and birds and amphibians and so
these these men and women are out 24/7
and we're ensuring that the their
habitat remains safe through them so
that when we do increase the population
we will have a place to release them to
definitely it really truly is a
proactive one plan approach I mean we're
working with with collaborative partners
all over using decades of science and
expertise and really making sure that
we're setting this a notch and rhino up
to succeed in the long term I think
that's what's different about this
project and I really think that we're
that we're setting up I have a dream
team for so much and rhinos and all
working from the same playbook to ensure
that this project is different and we do
bring this much in rhino back from the
brink what a wonderful note to end on
that conservation can be done in a
different way in a united coordinated
way with government with implementing
partners with the conservation community
fully United on this so thank you I know
that people in the audience probably
thinking how can I help
well what you can do is tell your
friends about this small singing hairy
Rhino and then visit our website here
Sumatran rhino rescue org to find out
other ways that you can get involved and
I want to thank Rudy Putra remotely and
our wonderful panel here and all of you
for listening thanks
[Applause]
wonderful that was that was incredible
wasn't it now why don't we give another
big round of applause to that Rhino he's
hanging out in the back with us so what
that's one of the most incredible things
about the